Would you please be so kind to introduce yourself to the audience of the Nexus Institute?
Where do you come from?
What is your background?
Thanks so much Rob, it is a pleasure to be
here with you.
I am an American philosopher.
My degrees are from Stanford and from Harvard
where I worked with people like John Rawls,
Robert Nozick and Tim Scanlon.
The great days of Harvard philosophy.
My career has been in Britain and I am now
the Chair of Philosophy and Law at King's
College London School of Law.
Being here at the heart of Silicon Valley...
will Silicon Valley be a part of the problem
or a part of the solution when it comes down
to the question 'What will save the world?'?
Humanity is moving from its old problems to
its new.
The old problems were crises of ignorance.
We did not understand the world well enough
to manipulate it and to solve our problems.
300 years ago, we did not understand the plague. It wiped out a third, half of cities all over the world.
Now we understand those kinds of problems. Ignorance no longer plagues us.
Our new problems are not crises of ignorance. They are crises of our own invention.
Our computers are so powerful, so present and so sapient we can hardly keep anything from them anymore.
Our weapons are so mighty, so devastating, they threaten human life on the earth. Even climate change is a crisis of invention.
All of these machines that we build, this
smoke coming off. All these people living longer, eating better, travelling more to see the world, to see each other.
Is it not poignant that our inventions start
avalanching into this mortal danger
that might really be problems for our grandchildren. Those are the crises of invention.
The hard things about the new crises are the
bads, so tightly wound up with the goods.
How can we keep all the blessings of our technology
and our industry while not allowing them to threaten our very way of life?
How does that relate to the title of your
new book? I read it with great pleasure: 'Blood Oil'.
There's a strange thing about our world: natural resources, which should be a blessing, are in so many places a curse.
There is one statistic to sum it up. Think of all the progress the developing world
has made in the last generation
China, India, even Africa is doing so much better - except the countries that have oil.
Countries that have oil are no richer, no
freer, no more peaceful than they were even in 1980.
That is shocking. You could think of Iran, Iraq, Syria, Libya, Sudan...
Saudi Arabia.
All of these countries are cursed by oil. And that is because of one very old, very
bad rule from the past which we have not reformed yet.
The rule that basically says: for oil, might makes right. Whoever can control oil by force these days, our law says: we buy it from them.
So, when Khadaffi took over Libia a long time ago, the world started to buying oil from him.
And than years later, when rebel groups took
over the same wells from Khadaffi, it became legal for all of us to buy from the rebels.
The rule says that whoever has the most guns will get a huge amount of money from the world and that money gives them absolute power.
Money comes in with no strings attached, it never has to be paid back.
Of course the power is unavailable to the
people of the country who have to watch while their resources are sold off to the world.
That money comes in and if it goes to rebels or to armed groups, they can use it to buy more weapons
If it goes to an authority, the authority
can use it to buy muscle and loyalty to stay in power.
And if it is the Saudis who get the world's
money for oil, they use that money to
spread their extreme, intolerant version of
Islam around the world and that is the version of Islam that we now see.
Mutated into jihadi violence, not only in
the Middle East and Asia but also in Europe and maybe even here in America.
Does this also explain how it is possible
that on the one hand Saudi Arabia
is a fertile ground for extremism spreading around the world in the shape of IS or other monsters and at the same time
- it is now April 2016 - president Obama is
paying his respects again to the king of Saudi Arabia
instead of standing up as he could stand up against Putin or Khadaffi.
In the short term it always makes sense to do business as usual.
In the short term it always makes sense to make an alliance with the authoritarian regime. How is that going?
How has that strategy worked in the past forty years? How did it go with the shah of Iran? How did it work with Khadaffi?
How did it work with Saddam? How did it work with Bashir in Sudan, Bashar [Assad] in Syria?
How is it working to try to keep the absolute power of oil in check by making alliances.
You just told us that you have studied at
Harvard with the great professors there.
Obama also was a student at Harvard, Harvard Law School. Why is it that you understand something he apparently does not understand?
John Rawls said: 'A politician looks to the
next election. The statesman looks to the next generation.
The philosopher looks to the permanent conditions of humanity and how they can be made better.'
Politicians always have looked to the short term. It is up to us as philosophers and as citizens
to look to the longer term and the world as a whole.
Do we find a clue to what will save the world?
Yes.
Tell us.
The clue to saving the world is depth perception: seeing from both eyes at once.
The world is a terrible place, compared to
what it should be: violence, extremism, climate change, resource management.
But the world is a much better place than it was. We really are living better than we were even 60 years ago.
The world is richer, human lives are longer, fewer women die in childbirth, literacy rates are
as high as they have ever been.
More democracies in the world than ever, and, shocking as it seems, it is the most peaceful time in history.
Both of these things are true. The world is terrible compared to what it should be
but it is better than it was.
Learning from the ways the world has gotten better can give us solutions for the problems to come
and get us to keep faith with our ancestors who struggled so hard to overcome their challenges
which were at least as critical as the ones that face us now